hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to man of man now I am
back here but through means that are not
proper there just so happens to be a
debug mode for this game so with certain
D bugs I have managed to get back to
where I was before and I've tried to
recreate the choices that were in the
previous playthrough as best I can
I think I got everything to be exactly
what it was before you know before the
[ __ ] happened and I'm right where I
should be
supposedly now whether or not that's all
100% true
I do not know also I don't know what
that is when it's just a box with a
lighthouse in it but what I'm gonna do I
still think that's Brad but I'm gonna
try to do the stabby I'm gonna try i'ma
try because if that's what it wants me
to do like hell I'll do it I just really
felt like that was what I needed to do
but it doesn't feel I don't lay in my
bones I feel like that's not what should
be the thing that is the thing you know
what I mean I feel like I know that
spread because it looks so similar so if
I stab Brad then Brad gets dead and I
shouldn't stab Brad is the thing like
that's what my gut tells me if I'm wrong
about this then I'm wrong but that's
what I think it's what I'm thinking I
don't know if it turns out that I'm
wrong again I I don't even know if I'm
gonna try to do it again I might as well
just go to my other save and like let
him die or whatever I'll do the best but
my gut doth tell me what is and is not
the truth of this and what is it is not
the truth of this is that almost like
I've been here before
i'ma look at the casket this time
oh yeah that's good
see I didn't look at the casket last
time what about this door huh wait
I'm sorry
pardonne-moi but what
if I had just gone to the door instead
of this hole in the wall I would not be
in this situation where I would be edie
if I had only done that also these are
the boxes with the skulls on him let's
open her up yeah let's do this
Manchurian Gold mm-hmm
interesting chemical leak I'm guessing
Manchurian Gold is definitely not gold
so that was not blood it was water so
what was the deal what's the deal then
huh you're making me think I'm crazy
when I know I'm not crazy oh I know for
a fact that I am NOT crazy
also my leg hurts but that's besides the
point I know I'm not crazy
so if I know I'm not crazy then I'm not
gonna let anybody tell me that I'm crazy
so is this just a factor of something
not happening the way that it was before
what is the deal what's going on here
that's a dead body and that's an
electrical leak hello how are you good
talking to you huh that's a problem I
guess we're just carrying on from here
then like nothing ever I'm so mad
if I had just gone to the door instead
what
[Music]
there it is there's that thing happening
are you gonna still do the thing to me
oh you are aren't you oh yeah oh no it's
Brad Brad hey Brad
do you
hey what's wrong what are you doing Oh
Brad what the hell Brad Brad
now now now Brad how now brown cow Brad
see that's what I was spotted if it
would listen to my cue presses oh I see
so you're doing it like this to me so if
I would have stabbed if I would have
stabbed I would have killed Brad and I'm
not about that I'm not gonna do that no
no no no no no no no no not today not
now not never never not now - never -
nothing
all right whatever you say you want to
drop me in the water I'll drop you on
your head my leg hurts
I might having a leg attack okay I
better get out of here pretty quickly I
don't know how long I can hold my breath
what about going this way how long can I
hold my breath for oh I can't go that
way well not long I just wasted some
time Oh what was that huh hello
[Music]
it's not real it's not real might be
real hey the way the wing the ring Oh
dig that Ewing right cool
no I'll take that never mind
cool as a cucumber what oh nevermind
it's a weird dream
now remember this
stop stop stop
come on what
what's wait what
[Music]
what just happened
what you you okay
Thanks I could have drowned we got to
get away he's still around that guy
let's go
Blizz who the who the hell is that who
the hell is that how'd they get out of
the water so quickly where where did
they get that knife did Alex drop the
knife up so very confused I'm very
confused you want to surprise me with
the whole higher adventure thing I gotta
say it's a good idea no it was I mean
it's funny I think it's funny but I
think the guys you hired are taking it a
little too far maybe and don't be cheap
you do feel like paying top dollar and
you get you get these guys that are not
cream of the crop they're taking it a
little too far
you know you get my drift so if you want
to feel free to pull the old plug get
rid of these guys I'm with you I mean
these guys are [ __ ] crazy they're
chasing it to wrap this ship is the
subtitles oh that's weird
okay not sure what's going and commas
cucumber again no more running for me
hey whatever you say buddy whatever you
say whatever you say hey a map well
that's helpful all right with field
notes from Warren officer Knight
all right good what does that do for me
though er mm Remini shown that's not
good all right I don't know how that's
gonna help me because frankly at this
point I don't even understand what's
going on anymore so I don't think I
don't think I'm gonna follow your logic
there and smash Duke the Duke of Milan
so that's not possible
Oh
all right how did I know I was gonna
smash that all right anyway we're all
going crazy here so maybe you're going
crazy okay
mission man overboard ordered full stop
and anchor at a 128 received reports of
a man overboard and sure that all units
under commander notified prepared to
assist in search and recovery of the
casualty this was no accident I saw him
jump well that's weird
what do I do that internal memorandum
toile officers captain Ford has ordered
that the consumption of alcohol is
strictly forbidden on this voyage any
officer found drunk while on or off duty
will face court-martial your alcohol
rations will be provided to you at a
later date Oh wonder why I wonder why I
mean it couldn't have just been that one
incident seemed like that uh if that was
the guy on the deck that punch told Joe
find everybody whatever this is
it's easy peasy can I please go around
this one obstacle Oh take this perfect
yeah they're gonna sing to me or I can
use you to Club someone to death
well that's a little peculiar but I have
seen worse hmm I'll take that please
thank you all right okay so that just
flew across the room and you're that a
yo you're that common collected about it
oh whatever
you know I have seen weirder things on
this boat here so Who am I to judge
ooh that's a creepy painting if anybody
knew what the hell was going on this
place of wait a minute captain icon here
now there we go
I hate that the only thing it has you
participate in is the opening and
closing of items like and clothes ah
again okay all right well that's
convenient
okay well weird but you know I've seen
weirder I have seen weirder I've always
seen weirder and I've seen weirder now
so I'm not gonna be worried about that
just good old gone rad organi as my
sister calls me hey I need to drain the
main vein here what is going on over
here what is it what am I looking at all
right whatever anyway see ya I should
really take a look behind this door
shouldn't stop talking to yourself
who you talking to should what should I
yeah maybe you should because the
cameras doing a weird move right now I
should alright okay I don't know why
you're so interested in getting this
open menu all you gotta do is use your
big strong hands it's gotta be bigger
and stronger about it maybe you can use
the candelabra to pry it open it doesn't
make a most weak little baby
maybe weak little baby maybe you can't
handle the door you can't handle what
that doors boom yeah there we go
hi Wow well that wasn't scary at all
that was in tight Oh
only my sister calls me by that name Oh
I got it I got it I got it that time
can't give me that's quite a scream
there Connie
made it MELAS I've nailed this
it's helpful now that I'm kind of
understanding that they're in the
direction that is moving whoa oh that's
not good Marilee I'm fairly well it's
just an old lady oh that's not good
that's what you call not good man I got
through those by the skin of a chess hey
as long as I'm quick hey I did it
whatever I did I've run enough I'm a
hiding kind of guy I didn't see a
fortune about this Oh easy I've done
this before
[Music]
easy peasy lemon squeeze me a drop make
dentures ship around here I don't know
what you were doing with your neck there
maybe you should run for it I'm guessing
it's just run you get quick times hide
and you get a rhythm game perfect
oh hey if she had different sound
effects this experience would be much
much different oh you ain't gonna get me
got it nailed it
I'm the best oh [ __ ] really
are you [ __ ] are you [ __ ] serious
you miss one [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate QuickTime events I hate
it I hate them so much
I hate QuickTime events so goddamn much
I [ __ ] hate QuickTime events they're
the stupidest [ __ ] they make no
sense this game has only this is a game
mechanic are you [ __ ] kidding me
the one I bet that was the last one
I hate QuickTime to this I hate
QuickTime of this we're gonna do this
right we're gonna do this easy and we're
gonna do it right and this time ain't
nothing gonna get me easy very easy look
how easy it is look how easy it be okay
okay was that the last one was that the
last one did we do it did we do zit no
apparently not we didn't do it all looks
so good
you don't look nearly as good as you
once did and you look really good before
but now not so good your spine doesn't
seem to quite be working good thing I've
got a diving board
okay I'm out confront you
mostly just be as jumping seemed like a
really bad idea oh okay
[Music]
are you doing
you scared the hell out of me the one
who should keep moving we need to find
the others
yeah jumping wouldn't have been the best
idea oh okay now we're back on track now
we're back on track baby back on track
okay so apparently that's Olson but
doesn't look a thing like also looks a
lot younger than Olson was oh yeah
that's why I don't recognize him because
he's completely [ __ ] different okay
bippity Boppity who put in video pity
like it's nothing okay yeah good thing
you didn't get a QuickTime event soon
[ __ ] watching you like a hawk this
time
because you suck in case that wasn't
obvious you suck we're gonna we're gonna
run
okay good call maybe I know what about
your boyfriend what about your my friend
what why would you you Juliana what the
hell
yeah that wasn't much of an obstacle
[Music]
okay is a busy
here comes more whoa hi hey
oh come on we got to get somewhere safe
okay
interesting
I'm more than a little confused
so was that really old sinner was that
not really Olsen we're gay I think are
you though are you you don't know that I
don't know that because I don't know
when I'm going to die okay oh hello I
have forgotten all about you to have
taken a turn towards the spiritual
wouldn't you say no have you figured out
what's going on how to stop it how to
save the lives of your poor unfortunate
to stowaways it's a drug in your
hallucination I hope although it seems
the ship's previous occupants never
managed to drug and design a lot of
deaths that night let me help you out
give you a little hint I don't need it
oh please please
well then how can I put drug-induced
those many forces at play here that a
more scientific and even some that are
more political supernatural perhaps
you've started to realize something
drug-induced hallucination everything
and everyone may not be quite what they
appear to be someone's a queen oh I hope
that helps
well aren't you excited to find out what
your poor unfortunates are making of all
this and how you might avoid any more
unnecessary tragedy go on back to it
speak soon okay cool great thank you
you're not much help I already figured
out everything that you were saying all
on my own so I'm pretty sure that I
don't even need your
what's wrong with you back there Brad
you lost your [ __ ] like big-time you
almost killed me what are you talk come
on no come on that's ridiculous
please not quit my hypothesis because I
gotta be honest it feels like there's
some like like evil like literal evil
going on down there uh-huh let's just
stay calm and relatively sane about this
my calculation this stuff I saw it's
like there were these old soldiers there
were bodies there was death but then
they came alive if that doesn't sound
that crazy right about now I saw
something this old lady I mean she was
batshit crazy like dinosaur old not that
that's a bad thing but she just like up
and vanished on Alex wasn't the only
Alex what are you talking about there
were things walking around with his face
on them Alex's face it was horrifying
he's so ugly more than one of the minds
way of talking that I'm smothering you
or something I know what I saw
let's time up okay this place is too
[ __ ] up to just be [ __ ] up you're
I'm saying I mean like something is
going on here so what do we know for
sure but we can all agree on drug
induced hallucinations uh did you see
the gold anything manchurian gold is an
actually gold
it's a [ __ ] chemical and it's leaking
all over a cargo hold - mm-hmm I found
this safety manual it seemed to be
geared at people who have to had no
chemicals that can cause heart
palpitations oh we found a guy who died
of a heart attack real sudden
unexplained what do you think actually
happened to this place the goddamn
mystery box what it is the ship is bound
for San Francisco but it hailed from a
water purification plant in China
apparently that's where it picked up the
manchurian gold yes this whole place
reeks of weird but it's not go stinky
weird and I don't like it but it's not
ghosts here's my nice sarcos Perpetual
bad feeling machine what happened to
everybody on this ship where did they
all go
this all feels more like a mausoleum
and a ship though the device they come
with the ship apparently getting scared
to death is an actual thing are you sure
that's what happened to these guys yeah
we know more than we did before that's
something at least we're wasting time
whatever we do we have to do it now
drugs time to get off the ship we're not
going anywhere without the distributor
cap
it just needs it to run good hold on
this ship's gotta have a radio an old
one if we can find anything use it
that's great but do you think it's still
there's no way you need to find a way up
there why why is everyone what there
would be no power on this ship how's
this hard to understand there would be
no power on this ship I think it's far
before the time of nuclear-powered ships
and I highly doubt that this is one and
they definitely ran out of oil or
whatever the hell they power this ship
with this was in 1947 wouldn't make any
sense if there was anything like that
excuse me a pardon
Wow excuse him why all right and if you
couldn't tell him over my previous state
of despair I think we were speaking
clinically totally according to my
calculations we are the [ __ ] okay you
know okay was this hey hey nerd why
don't you get your magnifying glass out
and look at this nerd hmm seems like
they shot plate sounds good maybe it was
these guns that took down the plane from
our dive maybe maybe they were so afraid
they shot at their own plane
yes it's all coming together nerd anyway
well it's a nice walk oh hi Julia so you
saw a whole bunch of people with my face
can't get enough of me huh great could
he use these if they weren't Swiss
cheese
all right cool good great good
observation hopelessness very good for
us right now
Morales running all-time high I feel
great Julia you look great hey all you
[ __ ] wait for me I've got on the way
man my leg hurts I don't know what
that's all about my leg hurts finally up
sadly no but
I'll keep my eyes open you haven't
really gotten very far and you haven't
done much to help so thanks ooh high
voltage
Oh interesting always ensure your mask
is fitted before assisting anyone else
with theirs if you detect gas so here
the gas alarm do not panic rain calm and
clearly shouts gasp gasp to warn anyone
in the vicinity hold your breath attach
the gas mask carrier by placing the bag
under your left arm pull the shoulder
sling over your right shoulder and hook
it into the bag hook the belt around
your waist remove the helmet pull the
mask up to your face with both hands put
the chanson inside the mask first and
then pull the mask over your face and
harness straps over your head remove any
potentially trap gas close the valve and
breathe out sharply to then push any
reigning air out of the mask with your
hands check for leaks I tightly
squeezing the flexible corrugated hose
with your hand and inhaling the mass
should crumple around your face if the
mask does not cumple there may be leak
readjust the mask to ensure it is snug
then repeat the process until the mask
crumples to ensure there are no leaks
wait know what about the backwards of
that no stop stop
you're an idiot in philippi Wow some
pretty dangerous cargo ok let go of the
hose you may now bring normally you may
remove your mask only with it they
really don't want ok alright cool good
hey can I take his mask alright I guess
we're still moseying then so if we're
all just suffering from drug and booze
to loosen nations on a ship that
mysteriously somehow has power left over
all the way from the 1940s and I think
we got bigger problems hey a little help
over here
a little help please I think this is our
way up give me a lift
you look strong no one else help hmm OOP
I'll pull you up
uh-huh is everyone else coming up - we
all sticking together oh good
okay I honestly thought that we were all
gonna split up and it was gonna be like
oh no we're all sticking together great
me and my bro being my bro we're such
good bros right bro
yeah by my calculations we are the best
of Bros Oh bro bro what you looking at
wait a minute
my secret senses are smelling something
oh you wanted me to skip right over that
didn't you oh you did didn't you well
I'm too tricky to be tricked by the Lex
if there's nothing here you set up a
separate camera angle for that I see
well oh I see yes yeah what speaking it
well this is where she's gone right
before huh I thought it looked familiar
god damn it damn camera angles change it
James are the buttons that I need to
press - can't believe this hey Jules are
you doing it mind if I get close to you
oh hey uh what about in here peekaboo
hmm over here okay but I want to check
out the rest oh but there might have
been something over there God ha what if
I fail oh [ __ ] me yo I got this
[Laughter]
I still wanted to check out what was
over there so I'm really mad quite upset
alright thanks bud I I missed out on
some secret but I guess it doesn't
matter now
my secret census went off at the last
minute there are a little little
misguided before and then now they're
not so good anymore anyway hey is this a
journal I can read great I sure do love
reading diaries ooh interesting
hmm ice well from the we heatwaves 20
feet no damage reported p.m. weather
continues to deteriorate it asked us the
forecast crew bearing up wind it's storm
force gaining strength weather is
exceptionally with several lightning
strikes hitting om but causing no
sustained damage we are leaking some
water but it is under control navigator
ports seedbed depth readable uh excuse
me
operational logs for SS s wrong am see
going down noon thick fog p.m.
increasingly had p.m. and 7:30 fog very
thick midnight p.m. dense fog continues
oh that's all okay I thought I thought
that was more I thought I thought there
might have been more about the thick
thick fog but it turns out that there
was not any more about that okay well
you know to each their own lik see and
cut that out for the love of God do not
show anybody that looks eaten please
Lucy in look seein look Sam okay anyway
I'm gonna pretend like you got rid I I'm
gonna I know you got rid of that I
definitely know you got rid of that okay
dead body not that interesting ah /
ammonition
interesting
oh okay all right cool
great Wow cameras really shaky on this
huh I didn't know I had any control over
the camera whoo all right let's see
what's over yeah okay yeah it would be
unpowered and old thanks Brett good my
calculations we are always a what is the
word sucked no cool
good great if you were headed to San
Francisco you'd be crazy to take this
route
sounds like they didn't want anyone to
know they were coming like I didn't seek
out in the ocean that doesn't make any
sense why would they do that it's a
military ship why would they do that
political mr. Madden said it's political
so if something political is going on
here political takes people on so many
different very routes we all know this
also can I mention no one picks up
pieces of paper like I was gonna read
that but then you decided to read that
so you kind of took away the only job I
have in here cuz my job definitely
doesn't involve actually controlling
this experience so whatever I guess I'll
just go on my own then is that wait take
a look I remember saying something about
a radio no frickin way this thing
actually still works well radio science
hasn't changed much in 70 years but the
power there's power that's the thing the
power I'll give it a whirl whirl it's
working
what's asking for know hey hey is anyone
out there hearing this hello [ __ ] we
gotta if you can hear us we're on a ship
an old freighter our coordinates are
approximately 12 degrees 30 minutes
south 151 degrees 20 minutes blasts
that's specific 8 here now we need help
[Music]
burana freighter abandoned huge and old
hello hello is anyone out there
please come in
Wow how convenient the power waited just
to go out at that moment great good yo
guys check it out okay we're not gonna
say anything about that words you're
gonna Sarah to me hold my ground lead
somewhere
yeah maybe down I don't way to get the
power back I need to get that radio
working I think someone should wait here
in case a message comes true I gotta be
honest I don't think I'm gonna make it
down there my shape
I'll go obviously I can do this
I should be the one to go uh I got this
bro bro I got I got this I'm not losing
you to this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm coming too
hey what Julian no uh you're not always
gonna be there to protect big guy I can
handle this
trust me a badass whoa whoa if Julia
says she can handle it she can handle it
case closed
Wow all right you and me Julia
all right that's a good start
Wow and none of the other people up
above we're like y'all right there Jules
you okay how's that leg good grades
everything still work I'm okay so what's
next oh we're gonna have to find the
generator if we can get it started we
can power up the radio copy that
we'll wait up here by the radio echoes a
little inconsistent but okay Wow
really Wow old technologies better than
our new modern flashlights after you
that definitely had fuel in it
I love amnesia the Dark Descent after me
that would get out of my way Julia my
secret senses are sniffing up us Norman
sniffing up a star's nothing here okay
all right my secrets Nance's has led me
astray ass nay a scenario I say my
secrets Nance's are on the fritz on the
schnitz hello aah
sick bay good great this'll be great
this is gonna go good for us sick bay
anybody dead in here Oh interesting
hey this is that same one brawlin ten
days brick fountain Joe was in the
sickbay Joe Joe huh wasn't really ten
days I thought it was one day wasn't it
one day I don't know anymore I don't
remember anything I don't even know who
I am so wasn't Charley in here not Joe
anyway hey the safes open
goody goody gumdrops all for me minutes
of meeting between scientists xcw Oh
Walter Bishop antsy DeVivo
Tom will Palmer with sergeant Peter
observing and nx4 meeting with our team
because says we can mutually learn for
the same thing the Western world must be
protected from the United States has
been aware of certain agencies investing
the aiding the chemical and biological
agents in warfare our act limited by the
Geneva Protocol have experiments we are
unable to describes an investigation
during tests the effects on human
subjects of the molecule crystal
structure hallucinogens codenamed
Manchurian gold chemical munitions
battery it was even relatively minor
observed to trigger significant
hallucinations men highly convincing
subject scene and hearing things that
were not really there
even the dangered was manifold and in
its intensity okay whatever you say man
whatever you say now I know what I
already knew before which is that there
was a chemical on here that's cause
people to hallucinate don't know why
they keep that in it was not many times
probably I don't even know you Alex and
I know that you've been wrong many times
in your life hey look it's that place
that people died first it's my boy Jo's
boy strong boy creepy boy also cause
until they have a heart alarm board
pretty handwriting this kid great
handwriting can't believe it stellar
even five stars I'll give that kid name
plus if I was a teacher I don't even
know what I am this thing looks like it
fell out of closet weird huh
what's our even it'll need a little
little little what does this say let's
see hmm interesting
private papers are clear crucial cos our
I don't know what see oh sorry is hello
Wow Jesus well I've never seen a dead
body before
oh well first time for everything all
right what else we got in there anything
good probably nothing it's all the same
stuff I saw before
just being rehashed to a lame game just
rehashing the same things over and over
again can't even believe it nothing
original ever in this game
in this world even Snoozeville this
generator doesn't look very generating
but okay I'll drop down then you don't
want to give me any secrets I see how it
is very straightforward then look look
yak with your eyes your special engine
good place to find a generator right
let's find out yeah I'm sure they still
have fuel [ __ ] no more letter I can drop
the rest of the way wait
oh yes smart movie yeah thunk I wonder
if something was supposed to happen with
that with her damaged leg but apparently
it's being really forgiving about this
okay whatever you say no of course he
didn't um hello yeah I think I'm
actually seen clearly for the first time
in a while nothing jumped out of me so
the ship was carrying maturing gold but
that was really some sort of palace
energetic Iowa been developed in China
during World War two we know it was
unstable and leaked all over the ship
maybe it's still here and it's having
the same effect on us paranoia
hallucinations that was what this stuff
was designed to do the crew was
hallucinating
we know they were scared of something
and the officers thought it was just a
bunch of jumpy gi's trying to get out of
guard all this crazy [ __ ] going on none
of its real
none of it's actually there this
couldn't have anything to do with the
plane wreck we dived I don't know it
seems like the plane came in contact
with the ship but it's just a theory Oh
God alright let's get going it's all in
my head now that i knowing is half the
battle the other half
advancements from demons that don't
exist and so on everything's good van'll
indian engine works rotterdam metal and
diesel engine number one seven three
four
your nineteen twenty gets old old news
who cares a new modern diesel engine
actually these are these old ship
engines are nuts like just the sheer
scale and what would have happened if we
went to Japan on vacation instead I love
it when we fight maybe if I turn this
one knob that'll fix everything no okay
no all right well there was no point in
coming back here was there alright good
what's over here
anything goody goody gumdrops anything
no it's just a big cycle oh yeah looks
blown out literally there would be
nothing functional in this ship it's
just it's stunning that it's even
floating oh look at this
I bet the fisherman brought it from the
Duke you think it still works it's gone
maybe a few minutes of your left
we're taking with us it's just gonna
slow us down
it's a rebreather okay I've never seen
anything about I didn't have any
premonition about this we're gonna take
no we should take it parts of the ship
are completely underwater
smart smart it's not like it's that
heavy anyway Judy de Beauvoir those
rhetorical cynically
I don't fantasize gentle ma'am a good a
good one
people self-study to fill me that job
the thing hey it's the thing
great
[Music]
he'll never know
oh yeah okay I'm worried cuz I did see
another door down the hallway but the
problem with this game is I never know
what the hallway is with the secret or
the hallway with the I gotta grab that
thing not this give me I need to grab
the thing hurt the thing go where's the
thing but what what what crap why didn't
you grab the cap that Alright oh that's
nice
hey cool nice alright oh oh I forgot
also where's the solenoid thing
are you leaving her to grab that I have
so many questions
oh he's got the problem with sharing
[Music]
Wow he is blind I guess technically is
blind in one eye so hey I did it go me
go gourds we need to start running again
we're good there now
okay alright did pretty good there oh
that's not good okay changing on me now
don't know
okay all right not changing it none of
that
raise your hands up floor no no not like
I said no changing
just put the gun down nobody has to get
hurt you think I wanted to hurt anybody
I didn't get a choice in this did I not
again it's all God changing on me
what what's changing stay away step back
from the mist hey there's no miss man
don't read it
don't break the mist wait what is this
mist what does it do its life bringing
things to life that shouldn't be alive
it's inside now now please just calm
down stop stop
one of us now I would you say that why
are you telling me what to do there was
something in the last room look what
something in the last room a fog or mist
maybe no sure we all did a little uh no
we held our breath no I mean the other
breath meant that the mist is not inside
of us I know you all fancy divers but
you expect me to buy that we've been
down here for hours
you've been holding your breath this
whole time holding your breath right now
wait we have a rebreather from our boat
what we've been using it to get the mist
out of us you know we could use it on
YouTube okay you keep that thing away
from me
to me I got the mystic meat all day it's
amazing it's only judging me
the inside ah distract stop lying you
cannot see it in the consumer notice
lying the misters inside
[Music]
hey hey well I saw that coming
[ __ ]
[Music]
okay all right well that was what fate
said had to happen that's what the
premonition said to do I think it's
better than he was shooting us right am
I right people am i right I'm right
anyway
sure okay Hey look water we needed the
rebreather yeah sure let's just start
drowning ourselves in puddles now why
not
why not whoa whose stock still there
buddy okay so interesting um all right
I'm gonna pause this here look we've
taken a tumultuous turn to this but
all's good I think that's what the
premonition said he was gonna shoot
himself and I think that's guidance
towards what you're supposed to do
because I think the only other turnin
was that the misty was gonna think the
mist was inside us and he was gonna
shoot one of us and I'm not about to let
that happen
I've worked too hard to keep people
alive so anyway that's all for this
episode I think this is gonna end in the
next episode so I will see you there let
me know what you think down the comments
below this game has some flaws but I'm
still enjoying myself so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you in the next video
[Music]